haha the Joe Rogan experience she gets a
good example of how things can change
right because Michigan used to be
Detroit used to be the most profitable
or the richest state or the richest city
rather let me get this out right Detroit
used to be the richest tip it used to be
a hugely rich city back when they were
making cars there yeah I mean they still
make some cars here but back when it was
the place
don't don't even get me started on the
American car industry but crazy you talk
about a group that took it for granted
and didn't adapt to the times yeah and
literally sat there and watched the
Japanese take all of their business they
they watched the camry become a chevy
you know used to be just leaned on by
Chevy versus Ford right you you remember
your family you had Chevy families and
Ford families it was but there was no
talk of any and they they they had that
market and they just sat back and let
built crappy cars and blah blah blah and
let that whole thing go it's ridiculous
Wow things get weird when you ship stuff
overseas to or ship jobs overseas you
know things are cheaper to make in
Mexico or they're cheaper to make a
China yeah that exists but but as far as
the cars they I mean American cars in
the 70s and 80s were garbage garbage
they were and and that was a choice the
cook the factory could have made they
could have made better cars and they
just chose not to do you think people
are gonna be more open to the idea of
american-made businesses supporting
american-made businesses after you
realize how difficult it is to get
things from China during a pandemic and
how we're so relying on China for
medicine and for electronics and so many
different things one would hope I think
there's two ways to do it either we do
that support American businesses or and
this is a worldwide thing open up to the
idea of globalization where things where
it's a global economy not an individual
nation economy you know then who runs it
China no the [ __ ] out of here America no
well the same people who run it now
right the bankers right there I mean
they don't give a [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] about where the
money comes from
they're running the money worldwide you
know they're there in in contact with
each other you know I mean that and I'm
not even talking from a conspiracy
theory thing like that's just how it
works
money flows throughout the world and and
so if you're financing I don't know if
you're financing Apple Computer an Apple
computer is building their computers in
China if you're to bank on Wall Street
you don't care you care about Apple
paying their stock dividends or paying
their bills you know what I mean so so
the bankers who run this who are behind
it they don't give a [ __ ] right I just
want to make sure it stays profitable
right they don't want to sacrifice that
for some ideal of it's good to buy
American right right but if you can show
some if you can show a way to profitably
make it American you'd have to get
people from America to really find value
in buying something that's America
because it would cost more like how much
would it cost
didn't we've done this before how much
would cost to make an American phone
everything-everything made over here
isn't even possible I don't think so
isn't that crazy
when you think about how many people
here have phones you know how many
people are addicted to phones we can't
even make our own but we gave that up
forever well can't we adjust own the
only way to just is if other countries
bring up their standard living to ours
and their income level ours then the
price of labour becomes the same because
that's the big variable that's the worse
you make so much value in things be an
American that you'll pay more for it the
same way you pay more for labels right
like you'll pay more for Nike than you
do for some no-name sneaker but then
then you have to make it a better
product well Nikes a really good product
but there's some sneakers that are not
as well-known that are also really good
products but they'll cost like half as
much yeah because Nike has a lot of
name-brand value I don't know why I'm
using the word Nike but it could be
anything you could have a deed is
there's a lot of things that people will
buy and they'll pay more for because
it's a brand yeah
branding makes a difference but it's
about the brand of America
made you again make it better this was a
thing right when an American car
automatically meant not necessarily
better right it's there's a pride and
owning Nike you you've owned something
that's got a great label what about a
pride in owning something that's made in
America but you also have faith in the
label in other words when you buy a Nike
shoe that's true you have faith that
this is a good shoe it's a quality shoe
right yeah so if if there was a time
when made in America meant it was better
right the cars are a perfect example so
you automatically bought it so now you
have to once again build that in and it
takes a long time this is another thing
about American economy versus a world
right American economy they're based on
the profits in the next quarter you know
whereas like Toyota was making plans in
the 70s to run the American took the
world car market in the 90s like they
plan long term you have to look at it
like that that it's not just a matter of
quarterly dividends you you have to look
at what are we doing with this company
and it has to constantly make more money
every year it has to make more money
than the last that's how you know it's
doing well yeah and you have
stockholders that you have to you know
your you have to listen to them and you
adapt and try to make a better product I
mean you look at like Windows right like
we're on Windows whatever we're not
still on Windows one yeah because they
were like oh this works better oh this
didn't work we got to change that oh
this works better and they you keep
adapting and changing the product or the
same thing now sometimes you know like
with the apple wood iPhones it's like
sometimes look you that phone you just
change it for the sake of change in it
like there's a reason there was no
iPhone 9 right they were like all right
we can't fool them anymore we got a
whole 10 because it was the tenth year
is that is that 10 year anniversary the
iPhone 1017 it started out in 2007 so
2017 is iPhone X to mark the 10-year
anniversary that's why there's no iPhone
9 but there is an iPhone 9 now it's yes
see I see yeah yeah so you need to I
think you can do it but you have to
build a value into making it a marry and
part of that is is marketing right like
the
one-fifty there's nothing more American
than a Ford pickup truck but it's made
in Mexico is it really yeah there's
f-150 plants in Mexico they're not all
made here in the US just like BMWs SUVs
are made in South Carolina yeah made in
Ohio so you and this is what I'm talking
about about the global part they figured
out well it was cheaper to make because
America buys the most SUVs so BMW said
well let's just make them there then we
don't have to ship them across an ocean
right makes sense and then the same
thing probably the NSX so like listen
there's gonna be a bunch of wacky
Americans buy this [ __ ] super
horsepower four-wheel drive Honda right
so you make it they're big now when you
talk about that value there are some
things like like Ferraris you know like
it's a Ferrari so it it has a value to
it and the fact that it's Italian adds
to the value of it right just yeah they
yeah when you talk about adding value
like some Italian like which is like
well yeah that's even though a lot of
times the quality was like you know
falling off or whatever but it was just
the fact that it's Italian so yes we
could do that but I don't know that that
anybody will
[Applause]